bonjour a tous encore une vidéo de
vacances format carte postale et je
voulais profiter pour revenir sur une de
mes toutes premières vidéos celle sur le
théorème des quatre couleurs alors
c'était vraiment une des premières
vidéos dont elle est pleine de défauts
mais je voulais revenir dessus parce
qu'elle a suscité pas mal de réactions
alors déjà pour commencer qu'est ce que
c'est le théorème des quatre couleurs et
ben c'est un théorème de mathématiques
qui dit que si on prend une carte qui
est faite de pays ou de régions peu
importe on peut toujours colorier cette
carte en utilisant seulement quatre
couleurs de manière évidemment que s'il
ya deux pays qui se touchent ils soient
pas colorier de la même couleur
alors ça c'est ainsi un théorème de
matin il est démontré donc il est vrai
rien aucun problème et est ce qui est
rigolo c'est que j'ai eu deux grands
types de réactions dans cette vidéo
j'ai des gens qui me disaient que banon
le théorème défaut parce qu'il avait
trouvé un contre exemple et donc il
m'envoyait des contre-exemples dessinée
et puis l'autre type de réaction c'était
des gens qui disaient que mais non de
manière évidente ce théorème était vrai
il n'y avait même pas besoin de faire
une démonstration
c'était l'évidence même et donc que
c'était limite un peu du foutage de
gueule que je le raconte ça alors
essayez de vous convaincre que les deux
types de réactions sont aux soins sont
pas corrects alors là il ya beaucoup de
gens qui m'ont envoyé des petits dessins
ou qui nous fait des petites description
disant qu'il avait trouvé un contre
exemple et il m'envoyait généralement
des choses qui ressemblait à ça voilà en
me disant que ben voilà il y avait
trouvé un contre exemple on ne pouvait
pas le colorier il fallait ça une
couleur par exemple pour le colorier
évidemment c'est pas le cas il ya
toujours une manière de le faire avec
quatre couleurs même si cette manière
cela peut être assez différente de ce
que les gens avaient en tête au départ
est donc généralement les gens ne
voyaient pas qu'il existait une façon de
les colorier avec seulement quatre
couleurs et même très souvent avec
seulement trois couleurs alors à
l'opposé je vous ai dit l'autre grande
low deux grands types de réactions que
j'ai eu c'est des gens qui me disaient
que mais c'était évident toute façon ce
théorème était vrai qu'elles n'aiment
pas besoin de faire faire une
démonstration et ce qui les faisait
tiquer c'est notamment une des
conditions du théorème donc je ne
parlais dans les vidéos qui est que
on ne veut pas que y ait plus de trois
pays qui se touchent en un point donc
pour vous avez trois pays qui se
touchent en un point c'est la situation
normale vous avez l'intersection de deux
frontières et donc ce que je disais
c'est que on veut pas pour que le
théorème cela valide qui est plus que
trois pays qui se touchent en un point
et beaucoup de gens qui disaient ah bah
oui forcément si on a posé deux
conditions là alors c'est évident que le
théorème est vrai alors premièrement
pour remettre cette condition sous une
forme un peu différente pour voir
qu'elle a absolument rien de rien de
scandaleux notre manière de le dire
c'est que si on a plus de trois pays
dont par exemple quatre pays cinq pays
six pays qui se touchent au même point
qu'un peu comme dans une tarte par
exemple il suffit de considérer que deux
pays qui se touchent simplement en un
point non pas une frontière commune on
n'a qu'à dire que ce touché en un point
ça n'est pas avoir une frontière un
appartement où on a dit ça on peut très
bien avoir sur la carte plus de plus de
3 pays qui se touchent en un seul point
mais on considère que deux pays qui ne
se touchent que par rapport à elles
n'ont pas de frontières donc ils peuvent
très bien être colorier la même couleur
donc une fois qu'on a mis sept cette
petite condition l'a priori à hirak
problème et puis pour ceux qui
continueraient à trouver ça évident que
le terme des quatre couleurs soit vrai à
cause de cette condition en fait je
voudrais vous faire part d'un petit truc
le terme des quatre couleurs il est vrai
sur un plan ou bien sur une sphère en
fait si on passe sur d'autres types de
surface il est plus vrai et il ya un cas
notamment assez amusant c'est celui du
tort à vous savez un tort c'est un c'est
un pneu ou un beignet comme vous voulez
une bouée et si on s'amuse à dessiner
une carte sur un tort et bien le
théorème des quatre couleurs n'est plus
vrai c'est à dire qu' il existe des
cartes où on peut avoir besoin de plus
quatre couleurs cinq couleurs si coup là
même jusqu'à cette couleur en fait sur
le tort le théorème des quatre couleurs
devient le théorème des sept couleurs
qu'il existe des cartes sur le tort
qu'on ne peut pas colorier à moins de
cette couleur alors je vous ai fait une
petite animation pour vous montrer à
quoi ça ressemble donc là par exemple
vous voyez un tort sur lequel il ya sept
pays et il faut absolument cette couleur
pour le colorier
parce que chacun des sept pays touchent
les six autres alors c'est quelque chose
qu'on ne pourrait pas faire sur un plan
ou sur une sphère
mais voilà ça marche avec un tort vous
voyez que ce théorème là en fait il est
loin d'être évident et encore heureux
puisque je l'expliquais dans ma vidéo en
fait il est extrêmement compliqué à
démontrer voilà et bien sur ce je vous
souhaite de passer de bonnes vacances si
vous en avez toujours et puis on se
retrouve bientôt pour de nouvelles
vidéos
à bientôt